so we've covered a lot of ground already
on why we need a transformation to
sustainable healthy food Tristan get a
very good example of what can be done as
one of the options and here we have a
panel where we have the opportunity to
now enter the really most challenging
and most inspiring part of the how how
can we accelerate a transformation
sustainable healthy food systems and
we're so privileged to have a fantastic
panel with Lindy we see down de su Banda
who have had privilege to work with a
long time was hitting the fan or prawn
network in Africa and you may say
something more about this during the
course of a work we have Nobel laureate
Rick Roberts 1993 Lord and medicine and
Peter tide Mars who is a leading
academic in ecological economics and I
know also a very strong scientist on the
whole area of protein from from
fisheries I'd like to start with you
lindiwe and your perspectives on on how
can we actually support a transformation
to sustainable healthy food with your
perspective from Africa and developing
countries thanks you're on I will I'd
like to propose some radical changes
revolutions that we need I think the
first thing for us in Africa is really
about eating local if you look at the
food we are eating and what I was raised
on currently Africa spends about 48
billion u.s. dollars on imports of food
per year and about 12 to 15 billion of
that is wheat yet when I grew up in my
grandmother's farm we had a diversity of
crops bread was not breakfast we had
young we had sweet potato we had pumpkin
we had local melons all that you could
eat the melons we could eat with milk
there was a variety and I think unless
our farmers or smallholder farmers go
back to what i call the rainbow
revolution where we are not just
producing one crop for income but we are
producing a diversity of
crops for food currently 75% of the food
we eat comes from just 12 crops and five
animal species so we are really exposed
as in terms of environmental risks and
we need to diversify the plate and
that's why I called the rainbow
revolution the second revolution i think
is critical is going back to the dining
room table we've lost respect for the
food we eat on the go yet when I grow up
dining time was special time it was time
for food that was cooked slowly in
community it was time for reigniting
conversations about what we are eating
weights coming from who is the best cook
in the house so in my own family of
introduced by force with my three
teenage children's at least one meal a
week we are going to sit together cook
together eat slowly in community so that
we can talk about the food that we're
eating and I think the third thing would
really be about behavior change
communication there's so much we don't
know about what we eat weight comes from
and how best we can use food to save our
planet and to produce healthy diets so I
think really it goes back from the
consumer through the producer side we
need to improve communication and that
brings need for science particularly for
us in Africa our foods we spend a lot of
energy leaching the nutrients rather
than closing the leakages so we need
nutrient-dense foods and yet we are
investing in removing the nutrients so
that the food is purified all in the
name of modernizing and westernizing our
diets so I think those are some of the
key things I would recommend thank you
so in some of you you're actually in
always saying that globalization and and
and what we're seeing today of the kind
of monoculture trend that that leads to
is a threat to the food security in the
future and that we need to enrich and
invest in the local indigenous food
cultures
we were producing commodities and not
food yeah and that's why we don't have
healthy food that's one key how and how
can we combine that Rick with I know
that you're passionate about the
scientific frontier of using modern
science to be able to reach the how on
sustainable food please share with us
your perspectives well one of the things
that concerns me greatly is that there
is this huge distance between the way we
think about food in Europe in the West
and the way that food is thought about
and is important in the developing world
and something that's been happening that
disturbs me very much is this anti GMO
movement that has taken hold in a big
way in Europe is to some extent seen in
many other countries and it is based not
on science not on anything other than an
emotional response to GMOs and so I
decided I was going to try to do
something about this I started a Nobel
laureate campaign Pro GMOs to point out
the benefits of GMOs to point out that
these are not dangerous and to try to
persuade the non-governmental
organizations such as Greenpeace and
many of the Green Party's but they are
actually spreading a very bad message
when they now go around and say in the
developing world these are dangerous
don't use them keep away from GMOs in
fact GMOs are not something per se
they're the product of genetic
modification every food we eat in the
West has come as a result of genetic
modification because in order to do big
agriculture you need to get good yields
you need to be able to make foods and
crops in a way that can easily be
harvest that can have good nutrition and
so on we've not spent any money doing
this really in the developing countries
the developing countries have been left
behind because they were not seen as a
good market big agriculture didn't want
to get involved in this but in fact it
is now possible
thanks to modern genetic methods the GMO
method it is possible to take crops that
grow in the developing countries one can
make them much better you can increase
yield we can increase the nutritional
value and we should be promoting this
and not telling the developing world
that GMOs are bad the GMO method is
perfectly safe the science is absolutely
clear we should embrace it we should
remember that in Europe we can choose
what kinds of foods we eat you already
seen examples where we don't like
tangelos because they have a tiny little
blotch on them but if you go to the
developing world in many many poor
villages they don't have this choice
they need whatever food they can get and
we should make sure that the
possibilities of better agriculture that
are available here in Europe also can be
used in the developing countries and so
that's what our campaign is all about
mmm i should say we have a hundred and
twenty-one laureates on this if you want
to find out more about it and there's a
website called support precision
agriculture dodo RG so we'll come back
to both of you to Rick and Lynn do it
with a question I'll pose it now but
just to give you some thought some time
to think about that and take Peter but
because I think many of us now start
thinking wait a minute Africa 1 billion
people the continent which has the
largest portion of malnourished
projected to be two three billion in
just 30 40 years what's the solution is
it Lindy was pathway to build on the
indigenous cultures from below or is it
Rick's pathway to use high-tech science
to really get an even more productive
delivery of food and I want to have your
perspectives or if it's both okay I'll
come back to Peter I know that you and I
talked just before about your conviction
that the how question has a lot to do
with awareness towards healthy
sustainable diets please share your
perspectives yeah thank you it's it's an
amazing thing we're in a room of over a
thousand people I think with waiting
lists for attendance it seems as if
everybody is
aware and concerned about the role of
food in environmental issues concerns
but from my perspective I think we have
a tremendous job ahead of us still in
communication we know the great work of
Tristan and Tara they spoke earlier but
I think we continue to need to find ways
to convince people I had an experience a
number of years ago where one of my PhD
students had Illustrated at a triple-a s
meeting impacts associated with beef
production and greenhouse gases in
particular one of the reporters they are
referred to beef and the ongoing
reporting as hamburger being the Hummer
of foods which was interesting and funny
until the hate mail started rolling in
it wasn't just directed at the PhD
student at our lab it actually came into
the university president so the the
scale of lack of awareness lack of
willingness to I think be open to
understand the challenges is tremendous
I think there's a lot of mixed messages
that we send each other that while local
makes tremendous sense in the context of
which he were describing so the shifting
agricultural production from commodity
to focus to more traditional foods
focused in a place like Halifax when I
have students argue for local food being
environmentally superior I think that
the evidence is extremely good that in
many cases it's not I would much sooner
have some so form of our food
particularly the higher impact foods
being brought in and these are issues at
aerospoke to and her sort of evolution
of her understanding being brought in
from distance if we're going to consume
certain foods we should try to identify
foods that are coming from places that
are lower impact production and forms
and bring them in in forms that are
lower impact in terms of transport so we
my point is we have a lot of
misunderstandings and I think we so
there's a continuing role for science
education and if
effective outreach to overcome a lot of
our very deeply held understandably
deeply held for the biases and cultural
constructs around what is acceptable but
a very quick get to you I mean you are
an economist do you think awareness will
be enough would you need really tough
environmental regulations like a sugar
tax practice on cars really I mean it
would be so I now unfortunately live
Canadian we now have a government that's
reimbursed the climate agenda which is a
great thing we have a government or
federal government that's talking about
the importance of a carbon tax and lots
of other countries are thinking about
this but if we implement it badly so I
absolutely awareness we need because
without that you're going to have
political backlash you're not going to
have people accept the imposition of
some of these measures but you I don't
think we should rely on people having to
take decisions on a daily basis on how
large the portion is so why don't we
send them other other messages through
prices but the problem is we don't do it
sensibly we are going to build tax
regimes that are going to penalize
certainly lower emitting foods and
reward others if a carbon tax is applied
exclusively on fossil fuel related
greenhouse gas emissions it will favor
beef which will be a problem yeah so
India where if you could you share with
us your vision for Africa how can we
actually feed our fellow citizens in
Africa by 2050 through systema healthy
food do you see a bridge between your
perspective and what Rick shared here in
terms of the GMO scientific frontier
with what I think the challenge we
always have with the GMO debate is that
it gets emotional because it's presented
as the magic bullet it's one of many
technologies and really it would be
criminal for governments to embrace this
without instituting bio safety protocols
so we've all signed on to the cottage in
agreement but we need to make sure that
the bio safety protocols are in place
then we are talking about choice
choice should be for the producer the
farmer and the consumer and they are
systems that need to be in place to
ensure that everybody knows what they're
eating weights come from and that they
have a choice but going back to the
broader question I think the challenge
for me is really let's improve
productivity yes the Green Revolution
that we've been pushing but better still
let's ensure that the food that we're
producing is nutrient dense and and
there are many opportunities right from
the seeds you've got your goal that rice
allowed to be launched that's
biofortification but that's not the only
answer we can look at normal
fortification along the value chain we
can look at the post harvest processes
of reducing loss we all know that if
food loss and food waste we're country
there will be the third largest emitter
of greenhouse gases so that already is
something and it's not just in the
developed countries in developing
countries most of the losses up to forty
percent I had farm level you know before
harvest so those are the leakages we
need to plug to ensure that we get the
yields but I want to speak about
agriculture that delivers nutrition
because for a long time we've been
hiding behind the word food security
that it's about access it's about
production and about utilization but
most of the training in the 60s up to
date has concentrated on yield and not
quality of food most of the training is
about farm level and we rarely go to
their household to understand the food
we produce who is eating it in what
quantities and how is it delivering
nutrition outcomes so as fun pan we're
investing in what we call a tuna which
is agriculture to nutrition which is
looking at what are the pathways for
ensuring that agriculture is nutrition
sensitive and this is a new language for
most agriculturalists because it's
always been yield now we're saying can
we deliver quality food that lends
particularly for
billion small the farmers whose priority
is to feed their families and to get
income and once they have the income we
want them to be educated to know what
foods to get and those foods should be
available and affordable and then you
treat nutrient-dense foods are currently
the most expensive in the African market
interesting no that's so diversity yes
clearly thank you so much can do a
social ecological food revolution
clearly so Rick am I am i pushing you a
bit too far me you pointing out from
from a science perspective of the
misunderstandings related to scientific
approaches through genetic modification
but would you even go as far to say that
without GMO we will fail on delivering
on food security for Humanity over the
next 30 years I mean I would go that far
yes and I can tell you the reason I'm
not saying it's a magic bullet it is one
of many techniques that one needs good
agronomy is also very important but we
do have the possibility using the GMO
method to improve crops to increase
yields to increase the availability of
nutrients and it is just one of many
techniques that can be applied in
general it is faster than traditional
breeding methods it is safer than
traditional breeding methods one of the
things that we don't do at the moment is
look at our traditionally bread crops
and ask how good are they if you look at
celery celery is traditional it's got
carcinogens in it it has compounds in it
that a skin irritants that can cause
dermatitis and yet we sell it because it
was produced by regular methods we think
it's okay we don't ask what are the
ingredients here but for gm's we have to
ask what are the ingredients we need the
same set of regulations for both we
don't need something special for gm's we
just want to know is the food safe
what's it got in it thank you just in 20
seconds Peter so I just like us very
quickly to jump from land into the ocean
I mean there is an
protein challenge for Humanity we know
this a big wedge is required if we're
serious about providing nutritious food
for seven to nine billion people you are
a great fisheries economist what what do
you see the potential in bako culture in
the futures is this a key wedge in order
to supply food for Humanity I think so
many others do but it's also a space of
contention because its innovative it's
emergent there are people that and I've
at times in my past and skeptical about
the implications of some forms of
aquaculture and of course it's not a
panacea not every potential genetic
manipulation one could do is going to
actually deliver the outcomes we want
similarly not every form of aquaculture
is going to be environmentally superior
to current alternative you know the
current mainstream livestock systems but
I think we have enormous opportunities
to shift resources terrestrial resources
crop based resources to feeding fed
aquaculture away from land-based
livestock and to find new species and
opportunities for culture we can't
continue to just to put it into context
in the United States and probably count
it as well we eat about four times as
many units of beef beef alone as we do
all seafood component the opportunity
there for shifting is huge so dear
friends time is out i think a short
summary would be to say that what our
panelists are sharing with us is that
we're talking about a science-based
inclusive fair transformation towards a
rainbow revolution which is based on a
diversity as a swedish smir goes board
if we're seriously going to successfully
do this transformation thank you so much
to the panelists and let's move on
[Applause]